WE HAVE A THIRTEEN BILLS ON OUR
FILE TODAY. FIVE BILLS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENSUS THOSE ARE
FILE ITEM.
NUMBER TWO AB FOR NINETY SIX
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB.
SEVEN SIXTEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN A. B..
EIGHT NINE SIX FILE ITEM TWELVE
A. B. FIFTEEN TWENTY NINE AND
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB. SEVENTEEN
TWENTY THREE SO UNLESS THERE'S
AN OBJECTION FROM MY COLLEAGUES
THOSE.
MEMBERS ARE GONNA GET THE MAGIC.
TAKE IT THE GOLDEN TICKET TODAY
AND THOSE BILLS WILL MOVE
FORWARD.
WE ARE.
WE DO HAVE A FULL FILE TODAY.
CAN ASK AUTHORS TO TRY TO BE
PRESENT HERE SO WE CAN MOVE
THROUGH OUR FILE.
EXPEDITIOUSLY WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE WITH OUR PRACTICE.
OF FIVE ALLOWING TWO WITNESSES
IN FAVOR AND TWO AGAINST.
ASKING THEM TO TRY TO CONFINE
THEIR REMARKS TO FOUR MINUTES IN
TOTAL.
AND WE ARE WAITING FOR AN AUTHOR
SO WE'RE GONNA.
WAIT TO CALL THE ROLL OF OUR
COMMITTEE.
FOR ANOTHER MINUTE OR SO.
AND THERE IS AN AUTHOR NICE
TIMING.
SO WE'RE GONNA ACT.
GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOES ARIAN
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE'RE GOING.
TO HOLD OFF ON A ROLL CALL.
YET THAT WILL BEGIN AS A
COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME YOU
HAVE A BILL TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS.
AB FOR FIFTY EIGHT WILL ALLOW
LICENSED OPTOMETRIST TO BRING
VISION SERVICES AND TESTING TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE CONFINED. TO
THEIR HOMES THIS CHANGE WOULD
INCREASE ACCESS TO UP THE METRIC
CARE FOR A CRITICALLY
UNDERSERVED POPULATION.
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
SENIORS AND INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
MENTALLY OR PHYSICALLY DISABLED
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS.
AS OF TWO THOUSAND TEN THERE
WERE MORE THAN THIRTY EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION PEOPLE AGE
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER IN THE
UNITED STATES.
UP TO THREE POINT SIX MILLION OF
THESE PEOPLE WERE CONSIDERED
HOME BOUND AND IN NEED OF HOME
BASED CARE.
ACCORDING TO THE TO SET TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA
STATE PLAN ON AGING THE NUMBER-OF INDIVIDUALS AGED SIXTY AND
OVER IN CALIFORNIA WILL GROW TO
THIRTEEN POINT NINE MILLION.
BY TWENTY FIFTY AN INCREASE OF A
HUNDRED AND 28% FROM.
TWO THOUSAND TEN STATISTICALLY
MORE THAN ONE MILLION OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE HOUSE BOUND.
AND IN NEED OF HOME BASED CARE.
VISION IMPAIRMENT CAN LEAD TO A
REDUCTION IN COMMON ACTIVITIES
SUCH AS SELF CARE.
COOKING READING WATCHING TV OR
USING A COMPUTER OR SMARTPHONE
WITHOUT AB.
FOR FIFTY EIGHT INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE HOMEBOUND WILL REMAIN UNABLE
TO OBTAIN PROPER I CARE REDUCING
THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE AND
FURTHER DECREASING THEIR
STANDARD OF LIVING.
I'M JOINED BY SHARM RIFFING ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSORED
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
OPTOMETRY.
GOOD AFTERNOON STRUCTURE MEMBERS.
DEALING WITH THE THE END OF A
FLU VIRUS SO PLEASE.
BAG THERE WITH ME -- BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR THE BILL
TODAY.
THIS BILL CAME ABOUT AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE PLACE BASED PRACTICE
OF OPTOMETRISTS AND THIS CAME AS
A SMALL PART THAT WE FELT.
BUT ALONG WITH STAKEHOLDERS
COULD COULDN'T ALLOW A FURTHER
ACCESS BUT OF COURSE STILL GIVE
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
WE HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
YOUR STAFF AND WHEN I THANK YOU
SORRY GOT GREAT COMMITTEE STAFF.
TO PRODUCE WE FEEL IS A MUCH
BETTER BILL WE'VE GOT A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN ON
THE SIX TO ME PERSONALLY -- HELP
IN THAT -- AND OF COURSE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND JUST ASK
FOR YOUR YOUR A I BUILT ON THIS
AND OF COURSE HERE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU'D LIKE THAT WAS
ANSWER VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
SEE NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THREE NINE WILL
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS OR QUESTIONS ANYBODY
CENTER ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU MISTER I WAS LOOKING
AT THIS AND I'M REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH THE FACT THAT WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE CARE OF SO MANY SENIORS
THAT OUT THERE THAT NEED HELP.
MY ONLY QUESTION I HAVE BEEN IN
READING WAS THE THE TYPE OF
MOBILE EQUIPMENT THAT THE WILL
BE NEEDED AND AND THAT SORT OF
THING HOW WOULD YOU WALK US
THROUGH.
A HOME VISIT.
SO I CAN'T WALK YOU THROUGH HOLD.
AS NOT BEING AN OPTOMETRIST
MYSELF BUT IN DEAL IN WORKING
WITH OPTOMETRIST ON OUR BOARD WE
ACTUALLY D HAVE THIS SORT OF
ALSO RIGHT BUT AT THAT.
NOT LONG AGO WE INCLUDED THE
PRACTICE OF OPTOMETRIC CARE IN
OF RESIDENTIAL FACILITIES IN
CARE FACILITIES AND SO WE DO
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY NOW WHERE
OPTOMETRISTS ARE ABLE TO ARRIVE
WITH THE BRIEFCASE.
I'D BE ABLE TO GIVE A
COMPREHENSIVE EYE EXAM MUCH LIKE
YOU WOULD I WOULD EXPERIENCE
WITHIN OUR DOCTOR'S OFFICE.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS ADVANCED TO A
POINTWHERE OPTOMETRISTS ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
COMPREHENSIVE CARE IN A HOME
SETTING.
AND IF I MAY FOLLOW UP WITH WITH
THE ARRIVAL OF MALE FEMALE TYPE
OF THING BECAUSE YOU'RE COMING
INTO SOMEONE'S HOME.
WE DON'T WANT ANY.
COMMENTS MADE ANY ISSUES MADE
THAT -- MAIL ARRIVES WITH SEE A
FEMALE THAT SORT OF THING WHERE
THEY WERE THEY GOING TO BE TEAMS
IS THAT WHAT WE ENVISION DOESN'T
ISN'T -- S. TO BELIEVE THEIR B.
TEAM WAS A SERVER -- EIGHT EIGHT
OFF TO THERE WILL BE CARE GIVERS
OF SOMEONE WHO IS HOMEBOUND WILL
HAVE FOLKS WHO WERE THERE
PROVIDING OTHER CARE FOR THEM --
BUT YOU KNOW WE HOLD THESE
LICENSEES TO PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS THEY ARE DOCTORS WITH
DOCTOR EDUCATION -- AND OF
COURSE REALIZE THAT THEIR
LICENSE WOULD BE AT RISK IF ANY
SORT OF ACTIVITY WERE TO OCCUR
THAT WERE OF UNPROFESSIONAL
NATURE.
AS I MENTIONED I'M REALLY HAPPY
TO SEE THIS HAPPENING AND AND MY
ONLY CONCERN WOULD BE.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DOCTOR IN IN THE PATIENTS THERE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
SOMEBODY THERE. TO ENSURE
ADDITIONAL QUESTION ANSWER
ADDITIONAL HELP QUESTIONS THAT
THEY COME UP.
THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE NOT
I'M GONNA COULD.
HAVE THE SECRETARY CALLED THE
RULES WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
GLAZER HERE GLAZER HERE CHANGE
HERE.
THERE ARE TO LET YOUR PARTS
LETTER HERE DOT.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI HERE HILL.
PHIL HERE LEYVA.
HAN WILK PRESIDENT OKAY ALL
RIGHTS WE HAVEA QUORUM MANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SENATOR WE
WILL BECAUSE MOVE THE BILL.
LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING IN CLOSING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OF RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR VERY GOOD I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY OPTION THAT YOU'RE
PROVIDING TO A PATIENT IF
THEY'RE UNCOMFORTABLE IN ANY.
SITUATION THEY DON'T HAVE -- TO
TO ASK FOR THIS THIS TYPE OF
PROCEDURE AT THEIR OWN HOME
ALRIGHT OKAY VERY GOOD WITH THAT
LET'S A CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
HI GLAZER I'D CHIANG BY CHIANG
AYE ANGELA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
PAN WELL.
WILL DIE.
SO A NUMBER THAT HAS ENOUGH
BILLS OF THOSE TO GET OUT WE'RE
GONNA HOLD THE ROLE OF THE TRAPS
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING TO PRESENT IN THE
BILL.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO IN FILE
ORDER -- NEXT ITEM UP IS --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WELCOME.
AND YOU OF A COUPLE BILLS TO
PRESENT TO US -- TODAY.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT WE'RE GONNA
START WITH THE ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE FORTY FIVE IS THAT.
YEAH AND TESTED WELCOME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS -- THE BUREAU OF
CANNABIS CONTROL SUNSET REVIEW A
SIMILARLY PUTTING INTO PARITY
ADDITIONAL CENTS THAT'S WITH.
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT BOARD
SIMILAR TO MANY UNDER
DEPARTMENTS CONSUMER AFFAIRS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
ALL RIGHT ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MEASURE MEMBERS ANY FRANCO --
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE GREATEST WITH KITANO WHAT'S
IN HER MEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CAN WITH
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HI TINA WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
XENON VICE CHURCHES CHIANG IS
MOVE THE BILL.
AND THE SECOND I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
OKAY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
QUESTION IS THE FASTEST AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER.
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG NINE
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA PARTULA AYE
DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL HILL
AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN.
WILK.
WILL GUIDE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I'M A MEMBER THERE NOTHING VOTES
TO MOVE THAT BILL OUT WE'RE
GONNA PUT THE MATTER ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT UP I HAVE ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MEMBERS -- THIS IS --
THE BILL TO HELP FACILITATE THE
ACUPRESSURE BOARDS -- CONTINUING
EDUCATION APPROVAL PROCESS --
WITH ME HAVE BEEN BUT DEBT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF ACCU BUT
BEFORE TO SPEAKING SUPPORT.
WELCOME. TO THE BOARD TOOK A
PARDON THE BOARD TOOK A SUPPORT
POSITIONAL LANGUAGE AS
INTRODUCED AT THE MARCH TWENTY
EIGHTH AND TWENTY NINTH BOARD
MEETING.
THAT TASTIC ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WILL BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
I'D SAY NINE AT SENATOR ACTUAL
IT IS MOVE THE BILL SEC I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. FIFTY ESPIRAL
VERY GOOD SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL MISSION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
AYE DODD.
GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN.
WILK RIGHT LOOK AT IT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET APPLE HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP I HAVE -- ITEM
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVEN SEVEN NINE I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THIS BILL HELPS
WITH THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARDS
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS AND AGAIN
HAVE OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BEEN BUDDY A OF THE
BOARD TO GET SUPPORT POSITION AT
THE MARCH TWENTY EIGHTH AND
TWENTY NINTH -- BOARD MEETING
AND AT WITH THE LANGUAGE HAS
INTRODUCED.
VERY GOOD I LOVE YOUR CONCISE
TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THE REQUESTED WISH CALIFORNIA
ACUPUNCTURE DIGITAL MESSIN
ASSOCIATION CAL ADAMA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
A WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW WILL BRING OUT A BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
THE BILL A COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
XENON IVAN RECOGNIZE EMOTIONS
SENATOR WILL CAUSE ON THE NUMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT
AS PART OF A RIGHT THAT CUT CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS AS THE PAST IT'S AN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHANGE.
CHING ARE THE LETTER.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN WILK.
OKAY THE BILL IS AN EFFORT TO
GET APPLE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER I UNDERSTAND
ANOTHER CONTROVERSIAL BILL HERE.
ITEM ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN TWELVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH RICHER AND MEMBERS I
FINALLY AT THIS BILL IS THE
COLLEGE CONSULTING ACT AS YOU --
ARE WELL AWARE THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF CHALLENGES WITH
RESPECT TO A COLLEGE CONSULTANTS
AT IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROFITING.
OFF OF INDIVIDUALS AT TO GET
INTO INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION WITH THERE'S NO WAY TO
TRACK -- SUCH A CONSULTANTS AND
THIS SIMPLY -- ASKS IN GUIDES
THE SECTOR STATE TO COME UP.
WITH THE TASK FORCE TO COME UP
WITH THE KEY PRINCIPLES AND
REGISTRATION OF FOUR OF THESE
ONLINE REGISTRATION -- APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PARTAKE IN SUCH A PROCESS AND
IT WITH ME ABDISHO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT TERRIFIC WELCOME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN WITH YOUR MICROPHONE
HONORABLY SO.
TRY AGAIN.
AREA.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LEE ANGELA READ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS
I AM PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME WE'LL
JUST SAY THAT WE FOUND THAT OUT
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
REGULATION THE STEREO.
SOMETIMES THESE PRIVATE
CONSULTANTS -- THEIR ASSISTING
FAMILIES WITH FINANCIAL MEANS
AND THE IMPEDE THE WORK SCHOOL
COUNSELORS -- THERE ARE SOME --
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE -- SOME --
POLICIES OVER THE PHONE BUT IT'S
VOLUNTARY WE THINK THIS WOULD --
GREATLY ASSISTED TRANSPARENCY
ENSURING OUGHT MORE STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS AT HIGHER ED.
IN TESTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND IN FAVOR.
REVENUE GERMAN MEMBERS -- TYLER
I DO ARMY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND YOU SHOULD HAVE
GOT A COPY OF THE OF THE LETTER
WHO WE THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR HIS ATTENTION ON THIS ISSUE
THANK YOU.
FORGET WHAT YOU HAVE A COPY OF
THAT LETTER.
I ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE -- BRING MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
SENATE ARCHULETA.
YEAH IN YOUR INVESTIGATION IN IN
INTERVIEWING -- I'M SURE YOU
INTERVIEWED QUITE A FEW PEOPLE
THE D. THE QUESTION COME UP
ABOUT PERHAPS LICENSING -- THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND AND CHAU BECAUSE
YOUR MENTION SEPARATING -- THIS
EXPERTISE -- AND LOOK WHAT'S
HAPPENED AND SO ON BEEN HAVING
SOME JURISDICTION DID THAT.
COME ACROSS IN CONVERSATION.
YES IT DID I MEAN I THINK A PART
OF IT WAS TO SEE THAT SO WHO ARE
THESE INDIVIDUALS AND EXACTLY
AND WHAT TYPE OF GUARANTEE RUBIO
IN TERMS OF CONSUMER PROTECTION.
OF THESE -- COULD BE SEEN AS
FRAUDULENT PRACTICES AND I THINK
THAT'S CERTAINLY WITH THE INTENT
OF WHAT WE WANT TO CREATE IN
TERMS OF THE BASELINE AT LEAST
THIS BEGIN WITH THAT OF THE
REGISTRATION TO FIND OUT WHO
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE -- AND
WHAT THEY ARE CHARGING AND THEN
HOPEFULLY BUILDING OFF OF THAT
BUT I THINK THAT'S HEADED IN THE
DIRECTION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS THAT TYPE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY -- FOR CONSUMERS.
THE FUTURE OF MOVE IT OKAY THANK
YOU ARE AT SOME NUMBER ANYTHING
YOU LIKE TO SAY IN CLOSING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- CENTER
ACTUAL AT ITS MOVE THE BILL THAT
IF THE SECRETARY TO CALL THE
ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHAIN I CHIANG
AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD.
GALGIANI AYE GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE PAN ALL
RIGHT CAN I WILK HI WILL DIE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOUR BATNA
THOUSAND HERE TODAY.
AS AN EFFORTS TO GET OUT WILL
HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIGHT NEXT UP ITEM.
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS.
AB SIX THIRTY WILL REQUIRE
THERAPISTS TO PROVIDE THEIR
CLIENTS WITH THE PRINTED
DISCLOSURE ABOUT WHERE TO FILE A
COMPLAINT.
ABOUT A THERAPIST SHOULD THE
NEED ARISE.
THE DISCLOSURE WILL BE PROVIDED
TO THE CLIENTS PRIOR TO SERVICES.
THIS WILL ENHANCE CONSUMER
PROTECTION BY ENSURING CLIENTS
ARE AWARE OF THE CURRENT
COMPLAINT PROCESS.
SHOULD ANY IS ISSUES OCCURRED
DURING THE COURSE OF THEIR
THERAPY.
IT ALSO MAKES A MINOR AND
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS TO CURRENT
LAW REGARDING CLINICAL SOCIAL
WORK STUDENTS AND THE LEADS AN
OBSOLETE REFERENCE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
KIM MANSON THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FOR THE BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
SENATOR AND GLAZER AND AND
MEMBERS I'M.
I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REGULUS OFFICE ISN'T AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW'S
OFFICE FOR OFFERING OUR BILL
TODAY.
AB SIX THIRTY TAKES STEPS TO
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS RECEIVING
THERAPY AND ALL SETTINGS BOTH
EXEMPT AND NON EXEMPT SETTINGS
ARE WHERE THE APPROPRIATE PLACE
TO FILE A COMPLAINT SHOULD THE
NEED ARISE.
AND WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TRAFFIC THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR PLEASE STEP
UP.
G. V. AIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LICENSED PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS -- WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
YET IT'S GOING TO A BEFORE
ABOARD DISSED -- LATER THIS WEEK
BUT WE ANTICIPATE AND TAKING A
SUPPORT POSITION ON THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS DANNY OFFER FROM PLATEN
ADVISORS REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS NAMI CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANKS FOR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE NUMBER BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ANYONE.
SENATE -- VICE YOUR CHECK IS
MOVE THE BILL LIKE TO CLOSE
SPECT WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
HI GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA I'D DODD.
GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE PAN I CAN I WILL WRITE
WILL DIE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU HAVE ENOUGH
VOTES FOR THAT BILL TO MOVE ON
BUT WE'RE GONNA HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVED ITEM.
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE ARE CURRY
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
SORRY FOR KEEPING YOU WAITING
TOO LONG THERE.
I AM IS TO TRY TO KEEP HIS ROLE
GOING FOR YOU GUYS YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I
AUTHORED AB FOR A ONE WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
TO ISSUE REMOTE DISPENSING
PHARMACY LICENSES FOR PHARMACIES
TO USE TELEPHONE MISSY TO
CONNECT WITH PATIENTS.
AND MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS.
HOWEVER WHEN THE LAW WAS
DEVELOPED THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
WAS TASKED WITH DEVELOPING
REGULATIONS TO SET THE REQUIRED
ADDITIONAL TRAINING NECESSARY
FOR A PHARMACY TECHNICIAN. TO
WORK AT A REMOTE DISPENSING SIDE.
THIS RULE MAKING HAS NOT BEEN
COMPLETED MEANING THAT TWO YEARS
LATER TELL A PHARMACY IN
CALIFORNIA IS STILL NOT A
REALITY.
AB SIX NINETY ADDRESSES THIS
DELAY BY CODIFYING THE
QUALIFICATIONS REQUIRED FOR A
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN. TO WORK IN
A REMOTE DISPENSING PHARMACY.
THE LANGUAGE COMES DIRECTLY FROM
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY'S DRAFT
REGULATIONS ON THIS ISSUE.
I'VE ALSO ALSO RECENTLY AMENDED
THE BILL TO INCLUDE PROVISIONS
ALLOWING A PHARMACY THAT IS
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED IN AN
EMERGENCY TO QUICKLY REESTABLISH
ITSELF.
IN A NEW LOCATION WITHOUT HAVING
TO RESTART THE FULL LICENSING
PROCESS AS IF IT WERE A BRAND
NEW PHARMACY.
THIS LANGUAGE IS SPONSORED BY
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY AND
CONTAINS AN URGENCY CLAUSE SO
THAT THE LAW CAN BE PLACED IN
FOR OUR NEXT FIRE.
SEASON [inaudible]
IRONICALLY NOW.
THESE CHANGES TO PHARMACY LAW
WILL HELP THOSE INVULNERABLE
AREAS.
ACCESS PHARMACY CARE.
I HAVE WITH YOU TODAY MR JOHNSON
WITH ME YOU ON BEHALF OF
CARDINAL HEALTH AND I ALSO HAVE
BEEN IN IT FOR NOT DANCING BUT
WELCOME [inaudible]
MARCH.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISSY JOHNSON
WITH NELSON MARKS MARIE HERE BE
HEART HERE ON BEHALF OF CARDINAL
HEALTH.
CARDINAL HEALTH IS ONE OF THE
NATION'S LARGEST WHOLESALERS THE
PROVIDE SERVICES -- DELIVERY
SERVICES F MEDICAL SUPPLIES
PHARMACEUTICALS TO HOSPITALS
CLINICS DOCTORS OFFICES
PHARMACIES XTERRA -- SO THAT
THEY CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICES
THAT ARE NEEDED OR THEY PROVIDE
THE MATERIALS THAT ARE NEEDED IN
THE DELIVERY OF HEALTH CARE.
CARDINAL HEALTH ALSO OFFERS A
VARIETY OF SERVICES TO
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES TO HELP
THEM WITH THE ECONOMIC VIABILITY
OF OF THE INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES
AND ONE OF THOSE SERVICES IS THE
TELE.
PHARMACY SERVICE I'M AS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID AB SIX
NINETY WILL HELP REALIZE THE
GOALS OF AB FOR A ONE BY
CODIFYING THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE REMOTE DISPENSING
TECHNICIANS.
OPERATING UNDER THE SUPERVISION
OF PHARMACISTS AT THE REMOTE
DISPENSING SITES.
THIS BILL AB SIX NINETY ATTEMPTS
TO EXPEDITE NOT CIRCUMVENT THE
DISCUSSION AND APPROVAL OF THESE
REQUIREMENTS SO THAT
CALIFORNIANS IN UNDERSERVED
AREAS WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
AND FOR THAT WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF MEMBERS DANNY
MARTINEZ THE CALIFORNIA FARMS
ASSOCIATION.
WE DON'T HAVE A LETTER IN BUT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ON
AND I WANT TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE THE PIECE DEALING WITH
NATURAL DISASTERS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A MEMBER.
OF OURS WHO OPERATES IN THE
PARADISE AREA WHO LOST THEIR
PHARMACY DO THE FIFTY TO THE
FIRE THAT WAS UP THERE. ONE
THING THAT WE FOUND OUT WAS THAT
AS SHE TRIED TO REESTABLISH FOR
PHARMACY -- SHE WAS TOLD SHE HAD
TO UNDERGO A WHOLE NEW LICENSING
PROCESS WHICH THEN DELAYS THE
MEDI CAL CATION IF SHE DECIDES
TO GO TO MEDICAL WHICH THEN
DELAYS -- ANY SORT OF HEALTH
PLAN OR THIRD PARTY PAYER
PROCESS.
AND SHE WAS LOOKING AT ABOUT
PROBABLY ABOUT TWO YEARS OUT
FROM IT RE ESTABLISHING HER.
HER PHARMACY DUE TO SOMETHING
THAT WASN'T HER PROBLEM TO BEGIN
WITH HER OR HER SHE DIDN'T
BECAUSE THEFIRE OBVIOUSLY.
SO THIS IS A GREAT GREAT YOU
KNOW QUICK FIX TO THE TO THE
ISSUE.
AND WITH THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR ABOUT.
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER OUT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON TIM VALDERRAMA
WITH WEIDEMANN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY HEALTH
SYSTEM PHARMACISTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO SAY AT THE
OUTSET THAT WE SUPPORT THE GOAL
OF THIS BILL AND THE PREVIOUS
BILL WHICH IS TO BRING PHARMACY
SERVICES TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES -- WE ALSO SUPPORT
ALL THE WORK THAT PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS DO AND WE HAVE
PHARMACY TECHNICIANS AS MEMBERS
OF OUR ASSOCIATION -- HAVING
SAID THAT WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
THIS BILL AS DRAFTED ALLOWS THE
PHARMACY TECHNICIAN WITH A HIGH
SCHOL DIPLOMA AND THE TRAINING
COURSE -- IN ADDITION TO LESS
THAN HALF A YEAR OF EXPERIENCE --
TO BASICALLY OPERATE IN A REMOTE
DISPENSING SITE WITH NO LINE OF
SIGHT SUPERVISION -- WE DO HAVE
LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE SHARED WITH
THE SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR -- WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH AN
UP WITH THEM ON THAT THE
PRINCIPAL THING WE'D LIKE TO SEE
HAS MORE EXPERIENCE AND WE'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THAT
EXPERIENCE -- BE IN THE RETAIL
PHARMACY SETTING -- HAVING SAID
THAT I HEAR THAT THERE MAY BE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
SPONSOR AND THE BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING
IN THE UP IN THOSE AND WE
HOPEFULLY -- CAN RESOLVE THIS
MATTER.
VERY GOOD ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ART CINEMA BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU AND I WANT THANK YOU --
THE MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY FOR
BRAINS BUILT FORD CERTAINLY
SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THE BILL -- I DID DID HAVE
TWO QUESTIONS ONE AND AND MAYBE
IT'S MORE APPROPRIATE FOR THE
BOARD WHY IS IT TAKING THE BOARD
SO LONG TO ADOPT SO WHY DO WE
NEED TO DO A BILL ALL -- I MEAN
I KNOW YOU'RE DOING THE BILL
BECAUSE THE BOARD HAS ACTED IN.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME I'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
WHERE AN AGENCY. FOR SOME REASON
CANNOT SEEM TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION.
IS ACTUALLY IS THE ISSUE ABOUT
THE LIKE THE TRAINING SO ONE
THOUSAND HOURS APPROXIMATELY FOR
A LITTLE OVER FOUR MONTHS FULL
TIME -- AND THAT WE'RE HEARING
MAYBE SIX MONTHS IS MORE
APPROPRIATE SO PERHAPS -- WE CAN
ADDRESS SO WHY.
ENTER A TERMS OF AND FRANKLY
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IT'S LESS
ABOUT HOW MUCH TIME YOU TAKE OFF
AS FAR AS BEING ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE CERTAIN SET OF
COMPETENCIES BUT MAYBE CAN SPEAK
TO THAT AS WELL SO WE WILL START
OFF WITH THE BOARD QUESTION LIKE.
WHITE WHY CAN'T THE BOARD IN TWO
YEARS GET THE REGULATIONS OUT.
CERTAINLY MISSY JOHNSON HERE --
I'D LIKE TO SAY THE ISSUE HASN'T
BEEN WITH THE BOARD OF PHARMACY
THE BOARD OF PHARMACY DEVELOP
THE LANGUAGE IT HAS BEEN
LANGUISHING OVER THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS -- WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN HOLDING?
REGULATIONS NOT JUST FOR THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY BUT FOR ALL
REGULATORY BOARDS -- IN A PRE
REVIEW PROCESS AND NOT HIS SLOW
DOWN THE THE PROCESS THE
REGULATORY PROCESS SIGNIFICANTLY
THE BOARD JUST TO BE CLEAR THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY APPROVE THIS
LANGUAGE ON FEBRUARY SIXTH.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THEY SUBMITTED
IT TO DC A IN JUNE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND DCA BEGAN A FORMAL
REVIEW PROCESS IN AUGUST OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SO THERE'S A
HOLD UP OVER AT THE DEPARTMENT
ITSELF AND NOT WITH THE BOARD.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE WENT TO
THE AUTHOR OF THE PREVIOUS
BILLING ASTOR IF YOU BE WILLING
TO CARRY LEGISLATION TO
EXPEDITED AS YOU'RE LIKELY AWARE.
THAT REGULATORY PROCESS EVEN
WENT OUT THIS PRE REVIEW PROCESS
CAN TAKE UP TO TWO YEARS SO HAD
WE GONE THROUGH THAT AND THEN
GONE THROUGH THE ENTIRE PROCESS
WE WOULD BE THREE OR FOUR YEARS
OUT BEFORE THIS WERE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED.
OKAY AND THEN I WAS STILL YOUR
SECOND QUESTION RELATED TO THE
HOURS I'M SORRY DOCTOR PAN -- WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT INCREASING
THOSE HOURS ARE PROBABLY GOING
TO GO UP TO TWO THOUSAND WE'RE
JUST WAITING TO GET FINAL
APPROVAL FROM THE BOARD BECAUSE
THIS IS LANGUAGE THAT I DID
DEVELOP.
OKAY AND I APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH.
ABOUT THIS ISSUE AND I AND SO.
YOU SOUND LIKE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
IS WHAT YOU ARE SUGGESTING IT
SIX MONTHS BUT WILL BE YOU'LL
FIGURE IT OUT OKAY SO I
UNDERSTAND BUT I GUESS THEY COME
AND I WOULD JUST MAKE ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS THE COMMITTEE OVERSEES
THE CA AS WELL AND PERHAPS WE
THROUGHOUT TO BE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
PASS LAWS AND WE WE VOTED FOR
YOUR PREVIOUS BILL.
THE MEMBER AND NOW TWO YEARS
LATER IT'S NOT BE IMPLEMENTED SO --
SO I THINK WE I THINK THAT'S
PERHAPS THE ISSUE OF FOR
OVERSIGHT TO SAY.
A WORD AND WE WORK HARD WE BRING
IN PUBLIC AND DOWN THE KEYS AND
AND YET WE'RE NOT SEEN BILLS
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE THEY'RE
STUCK IN THE AND I ALSO WANT TO
GIVE THE SPACE FOR THE
REGULATORY PROCESS RIGHT WE
SHOULD HAVE TO LEGISLATE EVERY
DETAIL.
SO I SO THE TO MEET A VERY
DISTURBED ABOUT THAT AND HOPE
THAT PERHAPS THE CHAIR MIGHT
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT --
AND MOVING FORWARD WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO MOVE TO BUILD AND VERY
GOOD -- A COUPLE THINGS ONE IS
IS THAT -- IT DOES COME IN THIS
TRANSITION OF ADMINISTRATIONS.
AND AS MUCH AS I SHARE.
CENTER YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DELAY I DO.
I ALSO ONE AT THE GRACIOUS AND
SENSITIVE TO THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS NOW
TAKING OVER AND TO GIVE THEM THE
SPACE IN THE ROOM TO TRY TO GET
IT RIGHT.
AND GET IT BETTER.
AD BUT IT DOES HAVE MY ATTENTION
AS WELL I APPRECIATE YOUR
OBSERVATION -- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WILL CENTER HELENA GO TO
YOU AND THEN I HAVE ANOTHER
COMMENT.
HELLO THANK YOU FINISH IF YOU
LIKE.
YOUR LIGHTS ON WHY IT IS AS TRUE.
RICHARD YEARS AS WELL BUT I JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON ON
SENATOR PANTS COMMENTED IN YOURS --
THAT MISTER CHAIR THAT THAT THE
DCA HAS HISTORICALLY
[inaudible]
DELAYED REGULATIONS AND THROUGH
THEIR BUREAUCRATIC.
NONSENSE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO STALL
THESE PROCESS THESE TO A OF AN
OBNOXIOUS LEVEL.
THAT IS PUT CONSUMERS IN HARM'S
WAY.
THAT HAS LEFT US ALL IN A VERY
DIFFICULT POSITION NOW LIKE
GRANTED THAT THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION HAS SOME TIME NOW
TO MAKE SOME CHANGES AND
HOPEFULLY THEY MAKE SOME SERIOUS.
CHANGES IN THAT -- THAT AGENCY
AND IN IN THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE
IT HAS BEEN HISTORIC AND IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND THIS.
COMMITTEE AND I THINK THIS
SENATE NEEDS TO TAKE SOME ACTION
TO DO SOMETHING WITH IT.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD SENATOR HELL
HOW DO YOU REALLY FEEL.
NOW YOUR AREA -- COMMENTS ARE
WELL TAKEN AYE I ONCE AGAIN
THANK THAT THAT WE WANT TO GIVE
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION AND
ABILITY TO DO THINGS BETTER.
BUT I THINK WE'RE ALL GOING TO
WATCH IT VERY CLOSELY.
YOU TAKE THOSE COMMENTS TO HEART.
I WANTED TO CIRCLE BACK ON THE
ISSUE OF THAT THE TRAINING TIME.
OUT ITS PROPOSED IN THE BILL AS
AT A THOUSAND HOURS -- A IN THAT
AND THEN THE DRAFT REGULATIONS
THAT WERE PUT FORWARD AS YOU'RE
WAITING FOR APPROVAL -- HOW MANY
HOURS ARE SPECIFIED IN THAT IN
THOSE DRAFT REGULATIONS IT'S ONE
THOUSAND RIGHT?
WERE THERE ANY OBJECTIONS THAT
WERE PROVIDED BY ANY PARTY TO
THE THAT THE ISSUE OF A THOUSAND
HOURS DURING THE REGULATORY
PROCESS.
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY OBJECTION
SO THE ISSUE THAT WE'RE HEARING
ABOUT TODAY AND I APPRECIATE
THAT.
HEARING THAT SURE WE ALL DO.
I WAS NOT AN ISSUE THAT THROUGH
THAT WITH THAT. SIX MONTHS ONE
YEAR PROCESS NO ONE'S RAISED ANY
ISSUE OF IT UNTIL.
THE BILL IS PROPOSES COME BEFORE
US THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING TO
BE CLEAR THAT'S WHAT BOARD STAFF
HAS INDICATED TO ME SO I DON'T
HAVE COMPLETE KNOWLEDGE OF THAT
BUT THAT'S WHAT I WAS TOLD WELL
THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT I'VE RECEIVED
IN MY COMMITTEE AS WELL --
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE SHOULDN'T
BE OPEN TO TO EXAMINING THAT
MORE CAREFULLY UNDERSTANDING WHY.
THOUSAND IS MORE JUSTIFIED OR
LESS THAN FIFTEEN HUNDRED OR TWO
THOUSAND I'M SURE THE AUTHOR YOU
AS YOU GO FORWARD THAT YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO LISTEN.
TO THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS FROM ALL
PARTIES -- AND THAT'S WHY I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING
FOLLOWING UP IN THIS FASHION
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A LITTLE
OUTSIDE THE NORM.
I THINK GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS ISSUE. FOR SO MANY --
JUSTIFIES WHY WE SHOULD PASS
THIS BILL TODAY HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
BY ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I WROTE IN
TO REMEMBER THERE'S SO MANY
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES THAT
WILL HELP HELPING WITH THIS BILL.
AND I ONLY REGRET THAT I DO HAVE
TO COME HERE AND ASK FOR THIS
NEXT BILL TO GET THIS TO MOVE
ALONG -- AND I HONOR THE
COMMENTS OF A SENATOR HILL AND
SENATOR PAN REGARDING TRYING TO
WORK WITH OTHER AGENCIES TO MOVE
OUR BILLS ALONG THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY ONE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
PERSISTENCE -- AND NOT ALLOWING
THE BUREAUCRACY DO -- TO PREVENT
THIS IMPORTANT BILL FROM TAKING
AFFECTS THE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT IS OUR MOTION FROM THE
THE MEMBERSHIP HERE.
CENTER PAN IS MOVE THE BILL
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING AYE ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA AYE DODD GALGIANI.
GALGIANI AYE HILL HILL AYE LEYVA.
THEY'VE AYE PAN.
AND I WILL.
OKAY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT OF THAT HOLE
THE ROLE OF THE TRAPS TO MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE.
THAT LEADS US -- ITEM NUMBER SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FOURTEEN BY
SOMETHING NUMBER WOULD
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SARAH AND TAKE THE
OPTION PERCENT -- AB SEVEN
FOURTEEN AB SEVEN FOURTEEN IS AN
IMPORTANT FOLLOW A BILL TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY OF LAST YEAR
THE REQUIRES PRESCRIBERS OF YOU
OFFER A CO PRESCRIPTION OF
NALOXONE WERE.
ANOTHER FDA APPROVED OPIOID
OVERDOSE REVERSAL DRUG WHENEVER
THEY OFFER AN OPIATE OR
BENZODIAZEPINE A PRESCRIPTION TO
SPECIFIC CATEGORIES OF AT RISK
PATIENTS.
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK IN EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENT RELATING TO THE
EXEMPTION OF VETERINARIANS WE
NEVER INTENDED FOR THIS TO APPLY
TO VETERINARIANS -- ADDITIONALLY
I WILL WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON THE SUGGESTION
RELATED TO THE DELEGATION.
EDUCATION COMPONENT OF THE BILL
HOWEVER I FEEL VERY STRONGLY --
THE THAT ONE OF THE PRIMARY
REASONS THE PRESCRIPTION OPIOID
CRISIS EXISTS THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY IS A PRESCRIBERS OF
WHICH I AM.
ONE OF FAILED IN THEIR DUTY TO
THEIR PATIENTS BY NOT ENGAGING
AND MEANINGFUL DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
THE RISK OF OPIOIDS ON THE
LIKELIHOOD OF ADDICTION AND THE
DANGER OF OPIOID ABUSE.
OR OVERDOSE EXCUSE ME -- WHILE
IT MAY BE MORE CONVENIENT TO
DELEGATE THE DISCUSSION AND
EDUCATION COMPONENT THIS BILL TO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE HEALTHCARE
TEAM I CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT.
UBER SHOULD HELP TURN THIS
EPIDEMIC AROUND BY HAVING THOSE
DIFFICULT BUT CRITICAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEIR
PATIENTS REGARDING THIS LIFE
THREATENING ISSUE.
HAVING SAID THAT I BELIEVE AB
SEVEN FOURTEEN IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL TO PROVIDE CLARIFICATION
AND A COUPLE OF IMPORTANT
EXEMPTIONS -- A. B. AT SEVEN
FOURTEEN PROVIDES AN EXEMPTION
FOR PRESCRIBERS WHEN TREATING
TERMINALLY ILL PATIENTS -- WHERE
THE ADMINISTRATION A LOCK SO
MAYBE CONTRA INDICATED?
IT CLARIFIES EXACTLY WHEN THE
OFFER TO OF A CO PRESCRIPTION OF
**** LOCKS WAS REQUIRED AND
CLARIFIES THAT IS NOT REQUIRED
WHEN THE DRUGS IN QUESTION ARE
ORDERED OR ADMINISTERED TO A
PATIENT WELL UNDER THE DIRECT
MEDICAL.
CARE.
IN IN IN OR OUT PATIENTS SAID
SETTING THE COOPER IS ONLY MEANT
TO BE MADE.
WHEN A PRESCRIPTION IS GIVEN TO
A PATIENT TO FILL ON THEIR OWN --
AB SOME FOURTEEN PROVIDE CLARITY
AND SPECIFICITY TO THE
REQUIREMENTS AND ENSURES THAT
THE APPROPRIATE EXEMPTIONS FOR
CO PRESCRIBING ARE IN PLACE.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
DR -- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS GOOD BILL TO
US TODAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT STEP UP TO THE
MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU MEGAN ALL RIGHT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION REALLY JUST
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE OTHERS
WORK ON THIS BILL IN ADDRESSING
THE CONCERNS -- THAT SOME OF THE
MEMBERS HAD AN IMPLEMENTATION.
AND I HAVE WITHOUT WE SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SUMMERS WITH THE
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MERRY MCKENNA THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MORE IS A RESUME WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
THE SUPPORT GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
FAVOR.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THE NUMBER BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR GALGIANI.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR I
KNOW SEVERAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
OLDER WHO HAVE BEEN GOING
UNDERGOING PAIN MANAGEMENT
TREATMENT FOR DECADES -- FOR
SERIOUS INJURIES THAT HAVE COULD
HAVE OCCURRED AND THEY HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MAINTAIN -- THEIR THEIR
WORK AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES
BECAUSE THEY HAVE GOTTEN THEIR
PAIN MANAGEMENT UNDER CONTROL
AND I THINK BILLS LIKE THIS ARE
TAKING US IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
AS OPPOSED TO SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION THAT'S OCCURRING
OUT THERE RIGHT NOW.
WHERE WHERE GOOD WILLING PEOPLE
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL ARE TRYING
TO IMPOSERESTRICTIONS ON SOME
OF OUR CLINICS -- TO GOAFTER
THE OPIOID CRISIS AND IN DOING
SO THEY'RE CAPTURING THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BENEFITTED.
FROM BEING ABLE TO ACCESS PAIN
MANAGEMENT SELF I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING BILL FOR TODAY I GET IN
THE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS --
SOMEONE NUMBER LIKE GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENT ON THAT VETERINARIANS
AND I AGREE WITH YOUR THOUGHT
PROCESS ON THE ISSUE OF
EDUCATION.
AND I I I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUING.
TO THINK THROUGH THAT ISSUE AND
IT AND AND FINDING THE RIGHT
PLACE OF RESPONSIBILITY AND
MAYBE EXACTLY WHERE YOU HAVE IT
TODAY SO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND WITH THAT -- SENATOR PAN IS
MOVE THE BILL FROM CALL THE ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
PREPARATIONS.
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE CHIANG.
CHING I ARE TO LETTER ARCHULETA
AYE DODD HI NOT AYE GALGIANI
GALGIANI AYE HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA.
LIVE AYE PAN.
AND I WILL.
THE GUY.
HI BILLS AT NINE ZERO THANKS
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THANK ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR UP NEXT AND
THEN GOING TO GO BACK TO THE THE
ROLE SO THAT WE CAN -- MAKE SURE
EVERYBODY ADDS ON THAT WISHES.
TO CENTER HILL IS THAT MOVING
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ANYBODY
WANTING REMOVED FROM THAT BEFORE
WE KNOWLEDGE THAT MOTION ALRIGHT.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SECRETARY CALL
THE ROLL GLAZER HI THESE ARE I
CHANGE.
CHIANG AYE ARCHULETA ARTICULATE-I DOT.
DOT AYE GALGIANI GALGIANI AYE
HILL.
HILL AYE LEYVA LIVE AYE PAN PAN
AYE WILK.
HI WILL DIE THE CONSENT CALORIES
OUT NINE ZERO SO THOSE EARLY --
RISERS DON'T HAVE TO STAY ANY
FURTHER WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
THROUGH THE THE AGENDA TO MAKE
SURE ALL THOSE WHO WANT CHAIR
BECAUSE I WAS AN EARLY RISER
HARDLY WAS SECOND HERE AT THIS
YEAR.
BUT I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PUBLICLY WISH --
CENTER DOT A HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
OKAY AS WE GET THE HAIR CUT SO
YOU LOOK YOUNGER THAT WAS A
STRATEGY.
ALL RIGHT GOOD IT'S WORKING.
BECAUSE HE WALKED IN LATE LIKE
YOU OWN THE PLACE YEAH -- CENTER
YOU DO GET A REVITALIZED YOU
WISH TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
OPPORTUNITY.
FOR YEAH.
ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA START --
TO WE'RE GONNA START WITH ITEM
NUMBER. ONE EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT THE GO BACK TO THE ROLE OF
THE SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL
AGAIN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS MISSION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BUT SIX TO ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR READING I DOT.
DODD AYE LEYVA LEYVA I'D PAN.
PAN AYE.
THE BILL IS OUTSIDE.
NINE TWO ZERO NEXT UP IS THE
ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
FOUR FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL MISSION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BUT SEVEN ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR READING HI DODD.
DODD AYE PAN.
AND I HAD BILLS AT NINE ZERO
ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B. SIX
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AROUND
A LOT SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTES EIGHT TWO ZERO DODD.
I HAD BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO MOVING ON TO ITEM FIVE
A. B. SIX NINE ZERO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT THAT'S
EIGHT TWO ZERO DODD.
HI DODD AYE AT BILLS OUT
[inaudible] NINE ZERO MOVING ON
ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
MISSION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
BUT SEVEN ZERO CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE DODD.
DODD I'D PAN.
CAN I AT BILLS OUT.
NINE ZERO ITEM NINE ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN SEVEN NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOVE THE
SECRETARY WOULD CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS MISSION IS TO
PASS THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTES. SEVEN
ZERO CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
READING I DODD.
DODD AYE PAN PAN AYE THAT BILLS
AT NINE ZERO AND THIS
[inaudible]
WHICH ONE I DON'T LEAVENED. ONE
LEFT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
TWELVE I ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS MISSION IS TO
PASS THIS AND APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT BUT STATE TWO ZERO DODD.
THOUGHT I'D.
THAT BILLS AT NINE ZERO BACK TO
PLEASE OUR AGENDA TODAY THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND ALL THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATED AND WITH THAT I
WISH EVERYONE A GREAT DAY.
MEETINGS A JR